23 years old is a pretty young age a To
Be A Millionaire but but then to have
achieved one's goals on paper yeah and
not feel successful I realized that I've
been lied to you by some kind of
narrative I think that's what I came to
learn over the years was that my
ambitions were fake they were they
weren't ambition they were insecurity
and there's a big distinction and most
of our lives are dragged by insecurity
and shame they're not driven by ambition
it's a tragic truth that most of us are
going to have to have our our Ambitions
and our our narratives fail us before we
realize their Illusions and their
mirages and their their false so I had
to go in search of something else a new
set of values to govern my life you
describe this as fake ambition yeah so
then what's real ambition yeah so real
ambition is is driven by your intrinsic
um desires and passions and interests
the things that you would do for free
they're the things that you would choose
to do in a world where you didn't you
didn't have to worry about money